Final Fantasy VII is an enduring classic
and the success of square enix's 1997
RPG also led to several spin-offs Crisis
Core Final Fantasy VII was the best of
them but if you didn't buy Sony's first
handheld console the PlayStation
Portable you missed it some 15 years
after its release you'll get another
chance to experience Crisis Core with
its remade version Crisis Core reunion
and it appears that it'll be very
similar to the PSP original only better
Gamespot got a chance to play a short
Crisis Core reunion demo at a Square
Enix preview event in Los Angeles what
was notable about the demo was just how
similar it feels to the original Crisis
Core in its gameplay and presentation
Final Fantasy VII remake set a high bar
for Reviving a classic game both
retelling the original game's story and
altering it in key ways to create
something new Crisis Core is a prequel
to The Original ff7 but despite its
links to ff7 remakes revised story
producer Mariko Sato previously told
Gamespot that reunion is hewing closely
to the original crisis course story
that's what we saw in the demo as well
the story and cut scenes of Crisis Core
reunion seem extremely similar to what
was in the original game the primary
changes and improvements are in reunions
combat though the original Crisis Core
was released in 2008 it brought with it
an action-centric focus on combat that
feels similar to what Square Enix has
done with more recent Final Fantasy
games ff7 remake in particular your
primary means of fighting enemies in
Crisis Core comes down to melee strikes
against foes Dodges to get you out of
Harm's Way and guarding to absorb
incoming hits although you only control
one character rather than a Party of
Three you can also equip Materia the
crystals that allow people in the ff7
universe to use magic that allow you to
cast spells or activate special
abilities during battle crisis core
keeps all its fighting in real time
using your special abilities magic
spells or healing items is done by
pressing different combinations of
buttons and there's no break in the
action like in Final Fantasy VII remake
with Crisis Core reunion however it's
clear that the movement melee fighting
and camera systems have been tuned up
making the combat feel like a Crisis
Core spin on ff7 remakes Foundation
Crisis Core reunion also retains the
gameplay ideas that defined the PSP
original you play as protagonist Zach a
minor character from ff7 seven years
before the events of that game the main
feature of fights is the DMW or digital
mind wave a slot machine like device
that sits in the corner of your screen
the DMW is almost always running and
when it lands on matching numbers or
photos of characters Zach befriends
throughout the game it conveys bonuses
that can have a major effect on your
strategy one bonus might make all your
magic spells free for a short period
giving you a great excuse to go ham on
Materia land on three pictures of the
same character and you can activate a
limit break attack similar to what's in
ff7 remake with the move changing based
on whose picture was matched the DMW
even determines when you level up we
played through two early boss fights in
the demo one against a pair of monsters
and another against the fire-based
summon spirit Ifrit combat is mostly
about quickly dishing out damage and
then dodging or guarding against enemies
as they strike back with the DMW
determining your moment-to-moment
strategy so you can take advantage of
its bonuses while the DMW encourages you
to use certain elements of your Loadout
or limit break attack it's not all
automatic just because a limit break is
available doesn't mean you have to
activate it immediately giving you some
control over when to Unleash Your
Biggest hits the main reason why you
might want to hold back and time your
offensive is a new system that lets you
cancel your enemies most powerful
attacks the two anti-soldier monster we
fought in the demo would occasionally
combine forces to use a big unblockable
ability called twin Tomahawk but unlike
in the PSP version they wouldn't
activate the attack right away instead
you have a short window to hit the
bosses while they charge up the more
damage you do during that window the
weaker and less effective their attack
will be when it's finally activated the
system gives you new agency to mitigate
boss's most destructive moves it's even
possible to completely stop an attack if
you manage to do enough damage although
we didn't play much of Crisis Core
reunion the improvements to combat were
really strong generally it felt like The
Crisis Core of 15 years ago but more
fluid and reliable with better
animations and an improved camera system
the game also looks great sporting
completely remade graphics and textures
to update it from the PS2 like look of
the original and bring it in line with
ff7 remake that has some drawbacks too
however Crisis Core was heavy on
cutscenes and character interaction and
while its character animations were
impressive for the time by today's
standards they're a bit stilted and
clunky reunion seems to maintain most or
all of the same scenes from the original
the dialogue is occasionally slightly
adjusted but the animations of the PSP
game seem to be in use here it makes for
some awkward moments like when Zach
turns around to face another Direction
in a cutscene and just rotates as if
he's on a car showroom pedestal these
moments are minor but they do act as a
reminder that this is an old game at its
core even if it might look prettier and
play better in a way though that can be
a good thing the original Crisis Core
was a game that many ff7 fans missed and
which wasn't even available to a whole
new generation of players but despite
being a remake the impression we got was
that reunion is The Crisis Core you
might remember or The Crisis Core you
missed out on from what we played Crisis
Core reunion looks set to be an
improvement of a fan favorite updated
just enough to make it the best version
of the game and a great opportunity to
finally check out or replay an important
chapter in the extended ff7 story Crisis
Core reunion is set to launch on
PlayStation 5 PS4 Xbox series xns Xbox
One Nintendo switch and PC on December
13th
[Music]